I have to start by saying
congratulations on your engagement we
are so thrilled and so happy and he's
here tonight and you know I have my
gorgeous ring alongside the other
gorgeous rings but we'll cover that one
up and look of it yeah it's beautiful
you know my kids were there when he
asked me and they you know gave their
approval and they were thrilled and you
know we have a great life today so it's
it's amazing I've been asking people
like you've Justin kind of got the
Fayette like the the Full House approval
like that you guys are a real sense of
family here and everybody's like yeah
thumbs up lucky for him yeah they love
him and yeah the first time I brought
him around I had to prep I was like okay
just so you know like Bob's gonna sit
down and talk to you and he's gonna kind
of question you about stuff and you know
you got to get in with Dave and John and
and I mean he we're all like family and
they love him so it's great he's right
behind you right now but he told me
personally that he's hoping to get an
invite to the wedding I'm just putting
it on of course he's my TV dad how could
I not you saying do you know what kind
of wedding you want big small intimate
we we haven't really been talking about
it we're gonna it's probably gonna be
like a couple years down the road
obviously things are a little busy right
now
so you know I want to be able to give it
time to plan it and really figure things
out so you know probably medium ish you
know invite the family the friends the
clothes people all that